my first Mike Pence spent much of this
week shuttling between United Nations
meetings in New York and Capitol Hill in
Russia he was overseeing Republican
efforts to bring a new Obamacare repeal
bill to a vote
mr. vice president good morning it's a
pleasure to have you back program good
to be with you all there's much to talk
about in terms of what the president
said and what you have said about Russia
but the story this morning is is about
the Muller investigation and I'd like to
ask you as it focuses on the president's
words in the Oval Office and actions in
the White House what impact is that
having on this administration well let
me assure you that as we see for the
first time three category four
hurricanes make landfall in the United
States as we see threats like North
Korea and an increasing destabilizing
role by Iran as we see challenges here
at home in health care and the need to
move this economy forward I can assure
you President Trump and I are completely
focused on the issues that matter most
to the American people know we're
cooperating fully with the special
counsel we'll continue to do that I
think special counsels got his job to do
we're going to keep doing our job and
and that's focusing on the issues that
that the president spoke about before
the UN and that we're working on before
the Congress do you believe the
investment mr. Muller is exceeding his
jurisdiction well I think I think that's
that's for others to say what I can
assure you is that we're fully
cooperating with the special counsel and
will continue to do that I've made clear
that during my time on the campaign I I
was not aware of any contacts or any
collusion with Russian officials I stand
by that and as I said will will provide
any information the special counsel
requires but you know honestly this is
not what the American people are focused
on okay let's focus on that we've got
some questions for you just quickly
though Paul Manafort was your campaign
chairman for both you and mr. Trump and
he was reportedly offering briefings to
a top Russian oligarch who has close
ties with Vladimir Putin about what was
going on was that appropriate I
you know I've read those accounts in the
newspaper and you know I know Paul
Manafort was on the campaign for at the
same time I was for about a month and so
look we're just gonna let this process
go forward got it we'll let the special
counsel to get the answers the American
people deserve but I have to be honest
with you Nora
honestly the American people as I travel
around this country the American people
are focused on the very same things that
President Trump is focused on every day
and that is how do we advance our
national security how do we make the
world safer and more peaceful place how
do we make America more prosperous and
the president is going to continue to
talk about donna ron deal in unison yeah
go ahead Nora on the Iran deal has the
president decided to desertification and
you know what that decision
well he'll indicate that decision it at
his time his choosing I know we've got a
deadline in the middle of October
whether we recertify the Iran deal do
you think that each Congress do you
think that he should I think President
Trump made his view of the Iran deal
very clear before the United Nations
General Assembly this week he considers
it nothing short of an embarrassment the
worst one-sided deal perhaps in American
history and the simple truth is that
that transferring 1.7 billion dollars in
cash to the leading state sponsor of
terrorism was a terrible idea
but that is not a violation of the
nuclear deal well look it's there's the
there is there is technical compliance
charlie and then there's the spirit of
the agreement Iran sits down with a
family of Nations enters into an
agreement regarding nuclear
proliferation I'm on not knew they were
happening before the nuclear deal
they've happened after the nuclear deal
the nuclear deal was stop Iran from
having a nuclear weapon rights what it's
about
Ron decertification is the issue many
nations have certified here and I never
Jim and I President to CERN I think you
heard the leadership of Iran just say
this week that they could restart that
program very quickly which which most
Americans know this is only a 10-year
deal
I mean I mean the Iran nuclear deal it
doesn't prevent Iran from obtaining a
nuclear weapon in a very real sense it
guarantees that they will after the time
period the president is deeply concerned
about this agreement
I think he'll he'll make his opinion on
it known at the right time but you know
at the end of the day we have to come
together as a world community and demand
that these rogue regimes including Iran
stop the destabilizing efforts stop
supporting terrorist activities and the
president simply determined to do that
just as he's determined to bring the
world community together we'll meet
today with South Korea and Japan's
leadership to further isolate North
Korea economically and diplomatic let's
talk about North Korea because he is he
has said that he would he has vowed to
totally destroy North Korea if necessary
he has also said he doesn't go to war he
does not want to go to war so what are
the specific circumstances that would
cause the President of the United States
to launch a war against North Korea what
does that look like the first objective
of our national government is to provide
for the common defense president Donald
Trump has no higher priority than safety
and security the American people and the
possession of nuclear weapons and
ballistic missiles in the hands of a
regime that routinely threatens the
people of the United States of America
and our allies is just simply
unacceptable does the present president
needs to wanted to make it clear and
he's made it clear that that that in the
event that North Korea takes action the
threatens the United States or our
allies that our response will be
overwhelming and effective I think to
follow on Gail's question that phrase
totally destroy North Korea because as
you know there are 25 million people in
North Korea and they could launch an
attack that would kill 25 million plus
in South Korea including many of our
soldiers that are there the defense
secretary mattis suggested there is a
military option that exists that would
that would save civilian casualties what
is that option and does it does it have
to do with kinetic options what is it
well one of the things President Trump
made clear from very early on in this
administration is we never talk about
our military options in detail in recent
years we've we've seen military
announcements about what we're planning
to do
anything to do in Iraq and planning to
do elsewhere look what what what what
the Secretary's made clear yeah what the
president's made clear is we have
military options but we earnestly desire
a peaceable outcome that achieves what
the Chinese Foreign Minister and I both
talked about yesterday charlie the
entire world community has one goal that
is the denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula if we want to achieve that and
they've had you know all options that
suggests that the point I think that
president that secretary Mathers was
trying to make was that there were
options that would not trigger a
reaction by the North Koreans well let
me just say that we have options I mean
there was some talk two three weeks ago
but some commentators that the most
powerful military on earth doesn't have
the ability to take action to defend our
people that's wrong I think it was we
have military Bannon who actually was
quoted saying that yeah we have options
yeah but but let me be very clear the
president desires a peaceful resolution
of this confrontation with North Korea
and and will continue to pursue that but
it all begins when the Kim regime
announces their willingness to abandon
their nuclear and ballistic missiles
program and not before thank you so much
yeah mr. vice president thank you as
always for joining us here at the table
with you know